So far we've examined what are called local illumination models, where an
object is affected by a light, and the result is sent to the eye. Light comes
only from, well, light sources. No light is reflected from other objects. There
are many more light paths that can be tracked. One rendering technique that can
simulate these is called ray tracing. We've seen how the GPU sends each object
triangle in turn to the screen and rasterizes it. Ray tracing instead fires
rays from the eye through each pixel. Objects are tested against each ray. The
closest object found along a ray's path is the one that's used to compute the
ray's color contribution. You can think of each ray from the eye as rendering a
single one by one pixel. One way to find the closest object for this pixel is
to send every triangle down the pipeline in attempt to rasterize it. Using the
Z buffer to keep track of the closest object. This is perhaps the slowest way
ever to perform ray tracing. In reality, researchers and practitioners have
spent huge amounts of time creating and tuning algorithms to rapidly find this
closest object along the ray. Where rasterization gets some of its speed is
from the fact that a single triangle usually covers a bunch of pixels. Various
intermediate results can then be shared when processing the triangle. At its
simplest, ray tracing can give the same result as rasterization. Each ray from
the eye finds the closest object along it. The effect of light on the surface
is computed and the result is displayed. However that's just the starting point
for ray tracing. For the light to surface pass, we've made one obvious
simplification for basic rasterization. Objects don't block other objects. In
other words, no shadows are cast. In ray tracing, adding basic shadows is
trivial. Shoot a ray from the surface to the light. If there's something in the
way, the light is blocked and can be ignored. Since all computations happen in
World Space we can avoid many of the precision problems found in rasterization
techniques, such as shadow mapping. Classical ray tracing also offers us the
ability to create true reflections in glass effects. For shiny surfaces, we can
spawn a new ray in the reflection direction. Whatever this ray hits is what is
reflected in the surface, and so can be factored into the ray's final color,
its radiance. Let's say our sphere is actually glass. Instead of simple
filtering, we can also spot a refraction ray and see where it hits. When it
encounters the other side of the sphere and exits, we spawn yet another
refraction ray in the reflection ray. We can continue to spawn rays until we
hit some limit.